very happy to welcome you here tonight
I'd also welcome you to pick up a flyer
of the upcoming events that we have here
we will be finishing our forum season
here on May fifteenth but next week we
have Jean trounce teen who is speaking
about her new book Shakespeare behind
bars and showing excerpts film excerpts
from her prison students performance of
merchant of venice and on Thursday of
that week we have Robert Taurus a gay
Puerto Rican educator who was the
narrator and subject of a really amazing
film called nuyorican dream and we will
be showing that movie and discussing the
film with Robert Torres afterwards and
on May seventh Mary mazi Oh Carol
Gilligan and Mary Jo Cain who is the
University of Minnesota's director of
the Tucker Center for Research on girls
and women in sports will be here to show
and talk about the title nine film
called a hero for Daisy which is about
the tenacious 1976 Yale women's rowing
team and Fran's de Waal a primatologist
from Emory University will be here to
talk about the ape and the sushi master
that has to be an all-time great title
on May knife and we end our forum season
with reycarts while the inventor
extraordinary and techy guy and author
of the age of the spiritual machine
who's going to be in conversation with
Howard Gardner the multiple
intelligences guru and the two of them
will be speaking about intelligence
computer in human so we would welcome
you to any or all of those and but of
course for tonight we're here to listen
to and experience and for those of you
who know Howard you know the informed
word is experienced both Howard Zinn and
Ray Raphael it's actually quite
wonderful to have them here this week
both Howard and Ray are known for their
social consciousness and their social
activism relic terms often associated
with the 60s and the 70s but this week
Harvard Yard has
in the site of an extraordinary burst of
social activism as Harvard students have
taken over Memorial Hall to protest the
failure of the university to pay some of
its employees a living wage I hope
you'll indulge me as I quote from an
open letter to the community from over a
dozen house masters as as it appeared in
the Crimson yesterday we as house
masters recognize that the issue of a
living wage affects the quality of our
community life in the Harvard houses in
the houses the living wage issue has a
human face the living wage campaign
invites us to ask if we are doing as
much as we can to assure that the
workers in our communities are receiving
adequate compensation for their work and
their contributions to our daily lives
we appreciate the care and diligence of
our students in bringing this issue of
wages to the attention of the entire
Harvard community in their work and
written reports over the past two years
we have deep respect for their
commitment to social and economic
justice and we support them in their
commitments and it has really been quite
extraordinary to see how the Harvard
community of has really rallied solidly
behind this issue we could never in our
wildest dreams have contrived such a
meaningful welcome for Howard and rape
two men committed to writing and
teaching about history from the point of
view of those who are often most
neglected and ignored Howard and Ray
exercise what they call a bottom-up
approach to examining new and critical
perspectives on the American past and in
doing so they've created histories which
resonate with all of us their histories
tell stories and through engaging us in
the struggles of ordinary people they
give us connection understanding and
insight two times and events which
previously seemed lifeless and
irrelevant people of all colors from
every class and economic level walk
through their books and in doing so help
us to understand not the extraordinary
but the ordinary events which
cumulatively make up the fabric of this
country
howard zinn is the series editor and
inspiration for the new presses People's
History he is a professor emeritus at
Boston University despite John Silver's
best wishes and author of a people's
history of the United States the
award-winning declarations of
independence failure to quit as well as
the recent memoir entitled and another
excellent title you can't be neutral on
a moving train he is also the author of
the play marks in soho ray Raphael grew
up in New York City received his BA from
Reed College in his MA from Berkeley he
then left academia to work in the peace
and civil rights movements of the 60s
before becoming part of the
back-to-the-land movement of the 70s
moving to the backwards backwoods of
Northern California removed from
electricity telephone and pavement while
living there he taught in a one-room
public high school teaching history math
English forestry and physical education
he's a prolific writer his works include
in everyday history of somewhere the
teachers voice the men from the boys
rites of passage in male America and now
a people's history of the american
revolution tonight we'll begin with
Howard Zinn then moved to ray Rafael and
we will finally give you all a chance to
ask your own questions so thank you for
coming Howard
thank you daddy angler for for
organizing this I think you organized
this you're the one who always calls me
so they happy to be here with radar fel
we actually yeah we've done a couple of
things before we just said something in
New York and we did something we've
together in California it's becoming a
thing and I'm very glad Dottie has
started off talking about what's going
on here the students sitting in for a
living wage because you're right that's
if we're writing a history of Harvard
University we might leave them out
unless we were doing a people's history
of Harvard University and we're doing a
people's history of howard university
and then we would have them then we'd
have the anti-war protestors of the 60s
then we'd have the members of the john
reed club we have all the people who are
turned over to the FBI by harvard
university now maybe I'm exaggerating
but Willis you know there's some
connection between harvard university
and the establishment isn't there i
think so no but no no of course not but
I spell-like contrast this is the sit-in
yes you know a people's history all
right contrast that with the other
Harvard oh and the other Howard is
epitomized for me by walking to widener
library and unless they have now removed
it but i doubt it but then when you go
up the stairs of widener library you see
this tribute to a soldier I'm tribute to
a soldier is good except that there's a
slogan that accompanies this tribute to
a soldier there are different ways you
can pay tribute to a soldier and
there's a way you pay tribute to a
soldier which is unsettling and this
tribute at hobbit it says happy is he
who with one embrace clasps death and
victory am i right do you remember that
yeah I didn't like that you say and
every time i went it to Widener yeah
that I was reminded of that so anyway
it's good these people who who is
sitting in our reminding us of the
invisible people and that's the idea of
a People's History you know that's what
ray is doing in those people's history
of the American Revolution I'm not the
co author of that book sent you write
some some people think you know because
my name appears I have to make sure you
know I want to be a co-author of every
good book but I'm not the co author of
that book but the new press which is
doing this series you know said to me
will you be general editor the series of
people's history series and I thought I
don't want to be general editor of
anything and then they because I think
of general editors being one of these
academic entrepreneurs you know no but
then they sent me raise book and I read
it I thought wow this is I've read
fairmount on the American Revolution
this is the best single book on the
American Revolution that i've read so
happy to do this so yes at the and
there's a connection between history of
invisible people in the past and the
story of invisible people the present as
the connection between yo the invisible
people of the American Revolution and
its time and the invisible people are in
our time and it seems to me you can you
can go from one to the other that is by
looking into by looking at the present
and in conscious of the people we don't
notice in the present you can then be
induced to look into the past and
say hey what are the one of the
counterparts these people I know about
today the cleaning people and the and
the immigrants and the hard-working
people who overlooked what is that
counterpart in the past and that leads
you to a people's history of the past
that leads you to look for different
things in the past and the kind of
things you get in traditional textbooks
or you can go the other way you can go
into history and read read a book like
rays or read other books that will tell
you about Native Americans and women and
black people and working people and
african-americans and then ask yourself
what is that counterpart today but in
either way a connection is made between
the past and the present and it's
important to know that because there's
no point going into the past if you're
never going to come out of it there's no
point going to the past unless you're
going to make a connection between what
you learn about the past and what you
see no in the present oh I must tell you
let's say how I came to this sounds very
dramatic how I came to my present point
of wisdom but I must tell you how I came
to think of you know doing people's
history I was in South I was living in
the South I was teaching at spelman
college in Atlanta Georgia and black
women's college became involved in the
movement and then began became involved
with snick the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee we got moving
around the South becoming a kind of
writer participant in the movement went
to Albany Georgia and selma alabama and
whoever snick was doing things wherever
the movement was engaged and going into
towns in Mississippi and jackson
greenwood in greenville and Hattiesburg
and so on and uh it occurred to me the
things I was seeing I know we're not
being recorded anywhere they're not
becoming part of anyone's history a lot
sure i was reading in the papers about
what the heads of the n-double-a-cp was
saying and what the latest legal
struggles were you know on the level of
courts and you know and what possible
legislation that might be in Congress
and what the president might be saying
but the things that I was seeing on the
ground level were not becoming part of
history and so I I wrote a letter to
Columbia University my alma mater well I
I don't have a maternal or paternal
relationship you know lets you know it's
let's put it this way i went to Columbia
University and that's why I got my
doctorate that's why I did my graduate
work and I knew they had an oral history
project which was new at that time now
oral history is known that time oral
history was new there's no studs terkel
around that well he was around but he
wasn't doing his thing and oral history
project and I had that done some work in
the Columbia University oral history
project and I knew what the oral history
project consisted up sister of somebody
interviewing decks secretaries of state
X generals X Admirals X almost everybody
who is important in the higher echelons
of government and industry know and you
know trying to catch them before they
died and that's the trick of oral
history you know and you know you follow
the health reports and you interview
people who are about to go and you get
them at the right moment as I knew
that's what the oral history project
consisted on and so I wrote the Columbia
University I wrote to the oral history
project I said hey well I didn't start
off that way because you don't write
that way to columbia university but I
said there's terrific oral history to be
done down here I mean come down send
somebody down here with tape recorders
take the people in Albany Georgia who's
been demonstrating them and who knows
what's happening in Albany Georgia tape
these people who've just come out of
jail in Albany Georgia oh good part of
the black population in Albany Georgia
has been in jail to talk to them go to
Selma Alabama take the Selma freedom
Cora
and a church rally that takes place
before the people are going out to try
to register to vote and some you know go
to Greenwood Mississippi talked to mrs.
ruby Pilcher who lives next door to the
Freedom House set up by the snick
workers and who brings them food and
takes care of them and talk to her about
her life and and you know that's oral
history I got this letter back from
Columbia University that's a wonderful
idea when somebody starts off that way
you get very suspicious a wonderful idea
you know it's like Gandhi said about
Western civilization a great idea you
know a one yet but we don't have the
resources we don't have the resources
Colonel university doesn't have the
resources to do that it's like Harvard
University doesn't have the resources to
pay a living wage to its work is right
there none of these people you know it's
like you know really it's likely it's
always that way the people with the most
resources don't have the resources you
know the United richest country in the
world doesn't have the resources to take
care of the health needs of 40 million
people you notice that's that's the
story on every possible oh they don't
have the words watch it but what it
really means is they don't have the
interest it means they don't care that's
what it really means it means that they
don't need these people they don't need
to represent these invisible people
because we're represented we represented
by the Secretary of State we represented
by the people up on high they're the
ones who take care of things and so you
know we don't we don't need these voices
that's the idea and the premise of this
is that this is one big family this
country and we all have a common
interest so that there for the people
who are on top they can represent
everybody we are divided by class and
race and sex and this and that no it's
as the Constitution begins a preamble of
the Constituent elvia those 55 rich
white men who got together in
Philadelphia this wonderful
multicultural group got together in
Philadelphia and we the people of the
United States you know no so they yeah
they think yeah we're all wanted
therefore we can be represented by the
people with money and power and so that
in fact we have the language to to
exemplify that we have that you know the
national interest shall we do this
should we go here should we send troops
there shall we bomb here well if it's in
the national interest whose interests
there is no national there's no single
entity there's no what couldn't could
want to get spoke a grand Falloon some
of you may remember a grand faloon is
this sort of something which encompasses
everything pretends to encompass
everything you see but it really it
can't you know it's a great big bubble
you see and which is artificial which
needs to be punctured by the truth in
order to reveal the complexities inside
in order to reveal the different
interests that are inside this bubble
and they're different interests in
America and so there's no such thing as
the national interest National Defense
national security or is it somebody's
securities that's you know closer to it
but but that's the that's the pretense
you know that we have this this all this
common interest and no recognition of
the fact that we are a class Society
have always been I do well you'll read
about the revolutionary period and I
mean that's one of the things that that
Ray brings out in this book but but I
mean this is true all through American
history can you could write a history of
the United States but overview history
of the United States and start off with
a sentence the history of the United
States is a history of class struggle
well that would be a dangerous way to
start off would be hard to get a
publisher a mainstream certainly a
mainstream publisher to do a history
nights but the truth is that yes we were
society riven by class right from the
very beginning riven by race riven by
right from the beginning it's not that
you know we were all pilgrims you know
coming here dressed in those funny
costumes sharing everything writing the
Mayflower Compact of all that stuff
beginning no no there was us and there
was the Native Americans there was a
black sand and slaves and they were
slaveholders they were the servants or
the Masters there were people given huge
grants of land you know huge huge grants
of land other people no land that all
property lists people from the beginning
and and up all through American history
you know I mean James Madison recognized
this when he was writing in the
Federalist Papers and he's trying to
persuade people to ratify the
Constitution he said well we need a
government we need a strong government
why do we need a strong government
because well there there's conflict we
their society is divided into factions
Federalist number ten right society is
divided into factions based on what some
people have property some people don't
have property there's going to be
conflict we've got to do something about
controlling this conflict we have this
nice new strong government it will help
to control this conflict he was very
aware as we're all the founding fathers
as well all those people gathered
together forgot a very conscious of the
rebellions that had just taken place
after the Revolution just shays
rebellion being the most recent one just
before and there's a there's an
important conjunction between the shays
rebellion of 17 86 and and the framing
of the Constitution in 1787 because the
framers of the Constitution were very
conscious of the fact that
out in western Massachusetts thousands
of farmers had gathered and rebelled
against the elite of Boston against the
high taxes that were they had to pay and
they had surrounded courthouses and they
had prevented the court proceedings from
going on this is a real rebellion and
was similar rebellions in other parts of
the country in Virginia in Pennsylvania
in New Jersey similar rebellion and no
the founding fathers were conscious of
this and one of them one of the
Washington's generals General Knoxx
wrote to him after shays rebellion said
hey I always think these guys start off
that way but then no they they know they
very elegant writers those and but in
effect in effect he said he said these
people in chase or Betty many of them
veterans you know veterans of the
revolutionary war captain Daniel Shays
himself a veteran many of these people
veterans the revolutionary they come
back and they find that all those
promises oh how universal a story this
is a veterans being given promises that
if they fight and sacrifice that they
will come back and there'll be a new
world and so on and and and knocks
rights to wash and so these people
fought and they think because they
fought in the revolution that now the
fruits the wealth of this country
belongs equally to them well this is
dangerous and so a government is set up
which is going to try to control
rebellion and that's that was the idea
of the constant the idea the
Constitution was not as even some very
prominent historians oh they wanted
these are very wise they were smart men
eloquent men song but the myth is that
their ideals to set up a Democratic
Society and you know liberty and justice
and no that was not the intent was to
set up a government to be able to
control things be able to deal with
Indians as if settlers moved out west be
able to deal with its flavor billions to
be able to deal with working people who
are built
that was the idea of it so well that and
so in fact the government was set up
there was able to deal with that and
he's been able to deal with out ever
since because ever since then we've had
government and legislation that was
represented a particular class of
Americans that didn't represent the poor
and didn't represent the black and
didn't represent the immigrants and
didn't represent the Native Americans
the history of legislation in this
country from that point to this point
has been a history of legislation to
benefit a very small group of people
been a few departures from that when
went at a time when they were great
social movements that that forced you
might say pressured for departures from
that in nineteen thirty is in the New
Deal in 1960s with those movements and
so on but by and large you know that has
been a story in history a society / my
class and race and and so on and so it
looking at the clock because you know we
have a deal I'm a very disciplined
person listen to orders and the people
who run these things are very tough
don't don't be deceived by their
appearance ah but um but the and so the
history when we have a society divided
this way history is going to reflect
those conflicts and those divisions it's
it's it can't be a neutral history a
history of which all the history
represents everybody history are going
to be written from a point of view and
some people going to be left out and
some people are going to be given
prominent attention and and so you well
it's it's in when you think about when
you think about doing history or writing
a presenting history it's inevitable or
I said that you didn't have an enormous
mass of data and inevitably you must
choose from that enormous mass of data
what you were going to present in in in
when you write history when you teach
history and you choose according to what
you think as important as you choose
according to your point of view and
depending on where you are and where you
sit and well who you're trying to please
you will have a different notion you
know of what you know is important and
so but if you look at it from the point
of view of people who have been
generally left out of the dominant
landscape of American history things
look different no American Revolution
looks different from the point of view
of Indians the Jacksonian period I
remember was taught to us as jacksonian
democracy those those words always went
together jacksonian democracy Jackson
was a slaveholder Jackson was a racist
Jackson was an Indian killer and in the
period of jacksonian democracy the the
industries were beginning in New England
and girls were going to work at the age
of 12 and dying at the age of 25 and and
you know in this period of jacksonian
democracy and also this is a period in
which the the army of the United States
under these Jackson's orders with
driving the Indians of the south
East out of their homes across the
Mississippi the Trail of Tears 4000 out
of 16,000 died in the Trail of Tears
this is actually a democracy so we're
looking at jacksonian democracy from
different points of view you have to
separate those two words you look at the
look at a civil war from the standpoint
of Indians civil wars of war for
liberation of slaves yes and in fact
that you know there's a kind of
emancipation that takes place as a
result of a civil war and yet during the
Civil War while armies were fighting the
Confederates in various parts of the
country other parts of the army were out
west annihilating Indian tribes more
land was taken away from Indians during
the years of the Civil War than in any
comparable period in American history so
yes if you look at the Civil War from a
different point of view you know yet
become something else the Industrial
Revolution a great economic miracle of
the United States and I remember sitting
there in class and marveling it wow
that's when we became a great economic
power and we ought to take with taught
to take pride in you know the wealth of
Carnegie well the achievements of the
great you know and then how many steel
ingots were produced you know and how
many miles of railroad track were laid
and you know it's all us it's all us
yeah our interests are the same you say
and but from the point of view of the
people who worked in Rockefellers oil
refineries the people who worked in the
Chinese and Irish immigrants who worked
on the Transcontinental Railroad in
front of Stanford people worked in
Carnegie steel mills no it wasn't simply
the great economic miracle you know and
there's a human cost to economic
progress which is not much dealt with in
the traditional histories of you know
the
that that great period of industrial
expansion between the Civil War and
World War one so uh yes at different
different points of view depending on
well take the progress to so-called
progressive era in American history I
say so called it wasn't clear so call ok
progressive or why some reforms were
passed Rosales present progressive ear
is exactly that period which more black
people were lynched in this country than
any other period you know Roosevelt the
great progressive Roosevelt you know
their ears are not Rushmore a warmonger
a militarist the lover of war men who
observes a massacre taking place in the
Philippines while his president and
congratulate the the military general
who orders the massacre of 600 filippini
men women and children and but you know
our heroes when you look at it depending
on your point of view the heroes are
different you know it's no longer
Theodore Roosevelt it's it's it's Emma
Goldman and Mother Jones you know and
Helen Keller and Eugene Debs you know
and Frederick Douglass and WB Dubois you
know you just get different heroes
depending on your point of view and I
have I have a few more minutes I I just
want to assure the people who are
threatening me that I have a few more
minutes you see and but I guess the one
thing i want to say ignore all the other
things i was saying
well preface that's all yeah the one
thing I want to say is that this this
approach to history this presenting of
history from the standpoint of what our
leaders do you know what is Congress you
know telling the story of America from
the standpoint of what are the statutes
passed by Congress and what a decisions
made by this Supreme Court and what are
the edicts you know by the presidents
and so on and and who are the military
heroes that we should direct statute to
this approach is a profoundly
undemocratic why and we're presumably a
democratic country but that's a
profoundly undemocratic approach to
history the leaving out of the point of
view of people who who are yes invisible
who don't have power and and what it
does that kind of history it creates a
passive citizenry it creates a citizenry
that believes that the important things
that are done are done by important
people and at all that is left for us to
do all is left for citizens to do is to
engage in the most puny active
citizenship and that is to vote really
because all we have to do is vote for
these you know we have a choice what a
choice we always have but to vote that's
our that's our that's the pinnacle of
citizenship in this supposedly
democratic country to vote for a or b or
a or a prime you see and but in fact the
history of the country shows that when
important gains were made an injustice
in economic justice or racial justice or
the attention paid to problems of women
and the existence of women when when
whenever progress was made it was not
made through the initiative of people on
top who was made by citizens by people
getting together by organizing by the
labor organizing by anti-war people
organizing by women organizing by
disabled people organizing by gay and
lesbian people or that's when that's
when things
it's important to know that so that you
don't remain passive citizen and so you
you understand that we all will have a
role to play it seems to me that that is
the importance of people's history
that's why I'm so glad that the Ray
Raphael has done his book and now he's
going to talk to you thank
so Howard said that the people who give
the orders around here and of course he
was the one to receive them so he told
me he says when I introduce you I want
to come I want you to come okay so he
can he can give a few orders 2 i'm going
to talk tonight about writing common
people into history why we do it what we
can learn from it why it's so seldom
done what are some of the obstacles we
face the obstacles let me give you an
example of the obstacles we face I moved
out to California in the 1960s and I met
many people from the 1960s California
style a lot of these people believed in
past lives and the ones who believed in
past lives it's phenomenal how many
people during the Middle Ages had been
princes and princesses very few peasants
in those times it was a reverse kind of
social pyramid so this is what we face
this is what we're up against this
actually goes quite profoundly deep in
our society in our consciousness what
common people that's my focus first let
me define that common people you have to
watch out with people the term people
because it's really that that term can
really be mustered from the left or the
right or even the center in its behalf
the center i'm referring to the will of
the American people uttered by ultra
privileged male politicians in this last
election a little too often for my
liking so I'm going to define common
people very simple definition as those
who do not enjoy the special privileges
of wealth prestige or political power or
alternately if you prefer all those whom
Alexander Hamilton warned us against so
why do we study common people ok this is
really several levels of it first on the
most basic level it's a question of just
simple social justice giving equal
airtime give credit where credit's due
beyond that what's really more important
is its through history that we learn how
to interpret the political process
through the study of history for years
in school
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth grade
so on until you're about as senior you
learn history before you learn how our
present political process is supposed to
work and in history then if you study
the workings of the from basically
top-down history of the elite that's the
way you just come to imagine that's what
politics is that's the way history work
politics works since it worked then we
can marginalize people in the past
therefore we can marginalize people in
the present so there's a whole political
message there and beyond that from the
historians point of view you want to
study common people just for the sake of
accuracy you leave out too much when you
don't imagine a history of the
depression that basically is a study of
FDR now this is you know the comparable
if you go back to the revolution we have
those things we have histories of the
revolution which are basically a study
not of FDR but of his counterparts and
they call that a history of the
revolution well it leaves out too much
let me give you an idea of some of the
things that leaves out that I cover in
my book in well what I do in my book I
take my lens my focusing lens i switched
from george washington over here about
90 degrees and come over to his slaves
his the Indians whom he displaced the
soldiers whom he commanded in the army
their wives their mothers the the women
who followed the army all these other
people so let's look at some of these
other people the slaves about one in
every five slaves in the south ran to
the British for their freedom during the
Revolutionary War this included 17 of
Washington's own slaves 30 of
Jefferson's own slaves and this was
really an exodus of biblical proportions
really greater than the more famous
Underground Railroad that followed so
huge consequences here it was I guess
Howard not have an argument as to
whether the Civil War or the
Revolutionary War was the largest Indian
War in our nation's history but
certainly it's what we you think of
Indian Wars as you know okay the whites
going out and after the Indians and it's
much more complex than that in the
Revolutionary War every single Native
American east of the Mississippi was
directly affected by the revolution air
war most of them cited one way or the
other and most of them sided with the
losing side namely the British this
opened up all the lands and and they
suffered the consequences it was really
the largest war indian war in the
nation's history the even the very
beginning of the war most people every
brother really agrees that the beginning
of the rep the american revolution
started in Lexington and Concord shot
heard round the world Paul Revere and
all that that's april nineteen 1775 the
previous summer 1774 there were in every
county seat throughout rural
Massachusetts thousands upon thousands
of farmers went to the courthouses
dragged out every British appointed
official deposed them drag them out into
the streets aren't on to the Commons
where they have to run the gauntlet they
made them take off their hats and recite
their resignations between maybe three
four to six thousand people lined up on
each side once was not enough they had
to do it over and over and over they
didn't have microphones and all the
people wanted to hear at every juncture
during these proceedings the people
would take votes was that the
resignation sufficient maybe he should
change it this amazing amazing out point
by the end of it you have the no zero
British presence in the Massachusetts
country provide 1774 eight months before
what happens eight months later the
British try to recall and they had
already lost and that is the
counter-revolution which for all these
years has masqueraded as the revolution
to beginning the revolution phenomenal
discovery it's like the emperor's new
clothes why don't people see that
because we're locked into certain myths
we get those missed by too narrow of
focus if you just look at what the
farmers were doing during that time you
see what's happening go on and on like
this all these people are seeking
freedom slaves the the farmers the
Indians they're all seeking their own
version of freedom it's not just the
taxation without representation people a
lot of the loyalists were seeking their
freedom you have in Maryland Delaware
Hudson Valley New York southern back
country you have loyalists who are
rebelling against the elite the Patriot
elite the elite were Patriots in those
areas these people become loyalists and
they fight for the loyalists for their
freedom lower
tenant farmers so pacifists they're
fighting for their freedom a whole
different way one in 30 free Americans
during the Revolutionary time belong to
a religious pacifistic organization
which opposed all war in this one in
particular they had to face the power of
a very oppressive government which which
was going at then they wanted their
money they wanted their bodies and they
wanted them to take oaths these people
wouldn't do a lot of them landed in jail
so there's a whole story in that women
we a lot of us know that women gave up
tea and in fancy ornaments for the sake
of the revolution well some women gave
up fancy teeth I mean fancy ornaments
and tea those who could afford it t was
an upper-class saying at that time a lot
of other women behave quite differently
you know the lower class women many of
them joined the Continental Army
basically they had nowhere else to go
these were basically homeless people and
they became camp followers other women
bia rioted for against war profiteers
for lower prices you have a whole other
level of involvement here when you look
at the revolution from the standpoint of
class to you find out that that it was
really in 1775 there was a massive
outpouring of all classes virtually all
classes except at the very top of people
against the British by the by the end of
that year most people with any form of
property whether that was a shop or a
farm they went home to tend to that
property there was nobody left except
poor people they had to resort to a
draft so in this draft if you you could
simply if you didn't want to go you'd be
drafted your number was called you
simply pay 20 bucks you get a substitute
it's an easy way out if you have the
money so by the end of the war you have
an absolutely an army which is
absolutely class in class driven lower
class only except of course with the
officers and impressionable young boys
that's who won the Revolutionary War
this is all by class now these are
amazing that this is not the simple
story this is not the kind of the
one-dimensional morality tale that were
raised with and we're getting all this
just but all we have to do is look at
the common people and all this just
emerges we can we can we find all this
these are not really that controversial
if you just look there so why aren't we
looking there that's the big question I
want to
us now what what are the impediments to
looking at people's history why why
don't we do it first of all there's the
need for to mythologize I mean all
cultures have have to create some kind
of sort of founding mythology why they
came to be who they are and implicitly
that's a justification who who they are
so we've done that we've created our
founding myth and in that myth we have
our heroes and these heroes are kind of
embody all the things that we supposedly
want all the virtues and the values that
we aspire to then added to this we have
the natural human inclination to
identify with somebody so history kind
of calls out for protagonist it needs
that one individual the single person
who embodies the attributes of the many
so we have George Washington is
courageous meanwhile there's 10,000
other men who are waking up about to go
into battle and having to face that
battle knowing they might die and what
do we learn we learned George Washington
is courageous it's kind of a shorthand
for the other people and then the other
people you know drifted drifted the you
know the through history just going to
go get left out of that of that telling
through this process we have Washington
marched against Cornwallis at Yorktown I
love that one Washington March because
Washington didn't march washington rode
a horse actually he walked i think
according to Groucho Marx he wrote a
white horse I learned that because it
was the only question I could answer the
end of his show what was the color of
George Washington's white horse so
he did make things easy because I was
kind of young at that time there was
also one about Grant's Tomb but anyway
where was I oh yeah so Washington is
marching in this kind of grand single
combat against Cornwallis this kind of
like leader down this top down it's
really its trickle-down you know
trickle-down economics ok this is
trickle-down history the historians
don't call it trickle down history they
don't give you know it's not the
official school of historians we are the
storage because Howard and I believe we
come from a school we're kind of the
school of people historians and they
don't say we're from the school of
trickle-down historians but they do say
but that but there's another related
words called dissemination and the way
dissemination works is a few people have
these great ideas these are great
thinkers and visionaries and wonderful
people who generally tend to be quite
well off and a lot of time to think
about these things and and they they
envision something and then it happens
so you know so you have like the in the
revolutionary period these great men
conceptualize the revolution and others
followed they just fall until fall into
line okay you have a few men kind of
like writing a play and the rest are
just delivering the script these top
people they're called leaders think of
what that means your leaders leaders
what does that mean you even out here
out on your protest there probably be
like you know rebel leaders or whatever
you now spoke you know leaders okay so
now if their leaders whose everybody
else as a follower right I mean that's
the only way you know in a multiple
choice test leaders opposite followers
choose number a and you're right okay so
you have leaders and followers what does
that do that means these people are just
like following along its way of
belittling they're very real concerns so
if you're against any kind of social
movement you have a great vested
interest in calling people leaders this
is the way it works is the way and is
the way we this kind of me know in the
sort of underlying grammar of the way
most history is told from the standpoint
of leaders by the way I have a very sad
tale to tell about this which is my
first review my first review was curcas
review and it said started
out people's history of the American
Revolution how common people shape the
fight for independence this is the story
of slaves women rebel leaders etc what
do I have to do to get through my very
first review rebel leaders you know this
is not the story of rebel leaders by the
way it's not my intent okay these great
people isn't the whole concept of how
history works it's not you know there's
much more dynamic flow between so-called
leaders and followers it doesn't work
from the top down just like that let me
give you an example Thomas Jefferson's
Declaration of Independence one of the
great documents of our time right
conceived by a mighty genius Thomas
Jefferson well it's a great document yes
and it says many great things so were
the sword several other documents which
preceded it on a local level which had
many of the same words which were made
by little county committees and
conventions and so on which drafted
these things and Jefferson had at his
disposal and he made it he did a
marvelous job of synthesizing all these
lesser-known works and coming up with a
document that then he is then credited
with and that's kind of a good model for
the way that the kind of the process of
leaders and followers you actually have
a ground swell of support doing a lot of
the work one person kind of putting it
together in some way and then getting
all the credit is kind of like you know
just spun out of his mind and in some
kind of sort of Immaculate Conception
sort of way okay anyway we're facing
this what we're faced with all these
sorts of things now in people's history
we also a lot of this is by the way
consciously manipulated to create to
lead away from the people to create
these special people on top let me read
you a little section here this is a
direct quote from Charles Thompson he's
the Secretary of the Congress I could
not tell the Continental Congress that
is I could not tell the truth without
giving great offense let the world
admire our Patriots and heroes they're
supposed to talent sand virtues where
they were so by commanding aminta
imitation will serve the cause of
patriotism in our country it was very
consciously creating this this kind of
image of heroes and he doesn't want to
burst the bubble and so of course at the
end of his
life he actually burns his papers so we
do not have you know what whatever it
was inside that bubble you know we don't
know what it was but we do get that idea
a lot of this stuff if we just take a
self conscious approach to try to
overcome it we can for instance this
marching Washington marched business in
in people's history I have I tell the
military story of the war I tell I give
a narrative this actually is a narrative
history it's not kind of a hanging
history or you know arguing points
there's a narrative a tell stories a
myriad of stories as a matter of fact if
you look in the index here and you see
all the people in there you're not going
to recognize anything these are all
stories about common people but it is
storytelling so when I come to the
military history I tell the story
through five common soldiers who were at
at the various battles and that's the
way that's the way I weave the tail okay
so so it can't it can be done but you
have to be very conscious about it even
so here's the biggest problem we face
which is more than just a problem of
attitude it's at a very concrete
physical problem that has to be
addressed and that's the problem with
sources where do you get sources for
slaves for Indians for tenant farmers
who don't right so on a lot of common
people particularly as we go back in
time they didn't write even if they did
write could write they don't have quite
have the leisure or they kind of venue
in which to write their letters aren't
going to be preserved in secure family
structures nice libraries passed on
generation to generation so you have to
overcome that how do you do it first of
all you do you look for what is there
and sometimes you get a little lucky out
of out of half million slaves in the
United States at that time there were
two complete narratives I mean foot by
complete I mean only 20 pages long or
something about their experiences during
that time these were people who did flee
to the British they were preachers so
they they basically wrote their memoirs
in religious journals that were
published during that time so we're
lucky we do have those two stories then
you have a few pension applications
later on but then oh here's another one
they an Iroquois warrior
black snake isn't really one of my
favorites he wrote a he didn't know how
to write but a friend of his learned a
little English and so he knew how to rig
him so black snake dictated to his
friend his memoir and it's just
fascinating stuff I include a bunch of
it in here incredible stories such as we
get an inside look about when the
British are trying to basically convince
the Iroquois warriors to join their side
and you get and he narrates the entire
argument the debate within circles
between the hawks and the doves and then
he also talks about what it's like to be
to be part of a slaughter what it likes
to be on a massacre kind of both ends
incredible document so you do get some
of this some want one great memoir which
is published I include some of in the
book but a fuller version is that the
shoemaker George Robert wells Hughes
which is a book that you several of you
might be familiar with then you have a
few a few soldiers did leave letters and
and went and later memoirs and the
things that you learn from me from these
first hand pieces let me read you one
because this this is um really in a
nutshell shows you how much you can
learn from a very personal document this
is actually a pencil net pension
application does this guy is applying
for a pension after the war what's
beautiful about this is you didn't have
to know how to write they would this was
oral history they would actually if you
were applying for a pension you would go
and they would take down your story so a
lot of time it says deponent says this
deponent says that it was really first
person kind of thing here we have this
guy is in the south and this is a story
he tells his name is Moses Hall the
evening after our battle with the Tories
we having a considerable number of
prisoners I recollect a scene which made
a lasting impression upon my mind I was
invited by some of my comrades to go and
see some of the prisoners we went to
where six were standing together some
discussion taking place I heard some of
our men cry out remember Buford this was
a site where the Tories massacred the
the Patriot prisoners and the prisoners
were immediately hued to pieces with
broadswords in revenge for Buford at
first I board the scene without any
emotion but
on a moment's reflection I felt such
horror as I never did before nor have
sins and returning to my quarters and
throwing myself upon my blanket I
contemplated the cruelties of war until
overcome an unmanned by distressing
gloom from which I was not relieved
until commencing our march next morning
before day by moonlight so he's he's
he's sensitive to the tragedies of war
but later the next day being on the left
side of the road as we marched along I
discovered lying upon the ground
something with appearance of a man upon
approaching him he proved to be a youth
about 16 who having come out to view the
British through curiosity for fear he
might give information to our troops
they had run him through with a bayonet
and left him for dead though able to
speak he was mortally wounded the sight
of this unoffending boy butchered
relieved me of my distressful feeling
for the slaughter of the Tories and I
desired nothing so much as the
opportunity of participating in their
destruction so you have this very
sensitive guy who doesn't want to do
this and that this kind of he gets he
gets into it this is this in a nutshell
as war this kind of strange twisted
logic of revenge so a lot of these when
you can find the sources take them and
basically in the People's History have
combed far and wide for every available
direct source and it's in there in part
and fully referenced for you to find the
rest okay beyond that though you have to
you have to be more creative I use a
trick I call reflected images we have
the the documents of the elite multi
volumes of them they're still they still
don't have Washington's all completed
they've been working on it for decades
now this is the new version of
Washington's so what by looking at these
things you can get glimpses of how of
the of the life for the common people
for instance 1777 July 4th this is the
first anniversary of the Declaration of
Independence Washington's General Orders
no women shall ride in the wagons what's
he talking about what's he talking about
is the women camp followers are riding
in the wagons he doesn't like that
because he wants the wagons to be four
and so they'll save their energy we a
month later absolutely no women riding
the wagons two months later if any women
ride in the wagon will be punished and
so on they'll be the dismiss from the
truth he goes on he keeps escalating the
punishment this goes on for four years
and until we find out from the 11 direct
source from a camp follower at Yorktown
that she arrived at work town writing
and wagon so what do we learn we learned
that the women road in the wagons we
learned that the the men appreciated
what they were doing they had a you know
they were into it we learned that the
men disobeyed orders whenever they
wanted pretty much so we learn all sorts
of things from these in direct indirect
sources reflect image reflected images i
call them one of the most incredible
reflected images really comes from
runaway slave ads as i said they're very
few direct statements from slaves but
consider this as i read us try to figure
out what you can surmise by the slave
owner the slave in question in the
nature of slavery all of this is very
there's a lot to be said this is
happening this runaway slave ad appears
really right when Lord Dunmore is
issuing the British governor of Virginia
is issuing his proclamation freeing the
slaves if they run to the British
absented himself from the subscriber the
fourth of this instant a Negro man named
limas he is of yellow complexion and has
the ends of three of his fingers cut off
his left hand he is well known in
Charleston from his saucy and impudent
tongue of which I had had many
complaints therefore I hereby give free
liberty and will also be much obliged to
any person to flog him so as not to take
his life in such manner as they shall
think proper whenever he's found out of
my habitation without a ticket for
though he is my property he has the
audacity to tell me he will be free that
he will serve no man and that he will be
conquered or governed by no man i
forewarn masters of vessels from
carrying him off the province
so I mean that's a whole textbook in the
nature of slavery right there sometimes
we don't even have that to go on we
don't even have reflected images okay
but we can still make statements let's
continue with a slavery thing by the way
I'm focusing maybe more on slavery now
but I also deal with with a full range i
have a slavery all the Native American
groups used to the Mississippi are
covered in here with complete narratives
loyalists pacifists women of all classes
the boys who did the fighting and so on
but I'm focusing on slavery here these
people did run to the British okay we
know that what we don't know is how they
made that decision but about a fifth of
them did for fist did not it was a very
dangerous task I mean a lot of them died
as a matter of fact about as many people
died trying to find their freedom in the
British as white soldiers died in the
war they died from in court or they died
from disease so that another unknown and
huge fact but they have to make a
decision are they going to go or are
they not going to go so how are they
going to do this maybe they're going to
call a meeting like this okay all the
slaves on Washington's plantation at
five o'clock let's get together i'm
going to decide we can have a rally you
know it doesn't work like that there's
slave informers everywhere this is
dangerous business we're talking about
undercover clandestine operations so we
know it has to have been because there
were slaves that were turned in they
have to have done it this way so they're
having these meetings they have to be in
small groups they're making these these
these decisions shall we run shall we
not so they're evaluating if we run
what's going to happen if we get caught
what's going to happen once we get there
if we don't run what happens with the
British then conquer the plantation
we're going to be sold into slavery go
to the West Indies they're trying to
figure all this out there trying to
weigh the dangers and the prospects they
have to be doing this we don't we have
no records or the journals okay but we
know they have to be doing it so I
include that in the story it has to be I
call this situational reconstruction I
don't by the way call that in this book
that's a fancy word for Harvard but
situational reconstruction in the book I
just talked about the kind of
deliberations that they must be making
because all I'm doing is I'm putting
myself in their position and
trying to evaluate their hypothetical
prospects now this is a there's a
movement in history which does exactly
this if you look into what's being done
and say diplomatic history now you'll
see people say you can't just look at
history as a train leading up to the
present you know everything has a neat
conclusion to it you know cause and
effect to something else that's that's
that's too one-dimensional and history
doesn't work like that at every point
there's choices and that's what history
is about is those choices and why they
make those choices so to make those
choices you have to go back to the times
and try to evaluate the prospects and
that's how you really get to learn about
how the people are experiencing those
times this is done in in all you know
sort of political history what I'm
suggesting as we take this kind of
sophisticated and very very obvious
approach all the way down to common
people through the full version when we
do this we find all the people are
making all the people throughout the
Revolutionary era are making very willed
and conscious choices about how to
participate in political action you have
and revering that a sophist he's in jail
because he won't take the oath his
minister is telling him saying you're
great Andrew because you're really true
to your beliefs so stay in jail and his
wife is telling him it's August the
crops are in if you don't get do
whatever you have to do it yet out of
jail we'd starve you know he's making a
decision he's trying to figure that out
you have Joseph plumb Martin one of my
five principal soldiers here talking in
very moving terms about his decision
shall he joined the mutiny or not he's
patriotic he believes in his cause he
suffered all this time and yet all the
people are so he doesn't want to go
against his army against his leaders but
they haven't been paid in there starving
does he mutiny or not you have corn
planter the corn planter the Iroquois
warrior he captures his own father
because his father is an Irishman as it
turns out ja no bail and he captured
what I mean what's he going to do with
his own father when he captures them on
the other side you have another Iroquois
captures his brother who's also fighting
on the other side this is really a civil
war this is happening all over the place
what are these people going to do how
are they how are they going to deal with
these kinds of decisions you have this
very moving one several cases you have
questions of soldiers the whites and
also some Indian soldiers coming up
across an unarmed man
you know and he's got the bead on him
he's pointing the rifle and he has to
decide whether to shoot the trigger pull
the trigger on a guy who he knows is
going to die you know that direct in
these guys for years later there this is
haunting them okay this is a view of war
this isn't the view of war that we get
you know when we just going to read the
revolution that's not the raw review
these people are making choices they are
political actors and there's their
actions are the revolution there's sum
total of actions to get the full story
that's what we have to do we have to
study how all these people are
navigating the troubled waters of
revolution seeking their own freedoms in
their own multi various ways okay when
we do this what we do is we go beyond
the simplistic morality tale which is
the usual revolution good and bad and of
course we're the good and we go and we
arrive at a much much more complex and
intriguing and really humanely full
picture something we can really identify
with much more indicative of the true
diversity that we're seeking today in
art for our nation's identity and also
as individuals so this is it this is a
people's history and I've done what I
could do people's history I think you
know I'm just show you the book I think
because you know I'm kind of actually
I'm kind of proud of it i think the new
press is has done a great job with this
book and i'm totally thrilled to be
involved with Howard on the project and
if you're into this thing there's
people's history okay you have partly
Howard to thank and also mark Favreau
who's where's Mark to see around here
stand up mark wherever you are where are
you are you here come on stand up give
it mark as my editor at new press all
the way out mark I have a reason for
this come on all the way okay
so I want you guys to recognize mark and
in this and here's my here's the reason
in my madness here because he's kind of
embarrassed cuz he didn't know I was
going to do this my reason is is this is
a people's history series and we're
really into input as to what that series
could be what you know further books for
their ideas for the whole whole business
so it's an open-ended thing Howard's
working on the series with Mark and I'm
just kind of like hanging out and given
my two cents so other people who have
you know two cents to give feel free we
hope the series is going to really help
to to push the study of history forward
and
I think what's happening now maybe some
people are probably need to leave if you
do do but we're going to stay for about
15 more minutes and Howard and I would
love to have questions and engage in
some dialogue so do we have
didn't think they did they look good on
you okay that is do we have people
waiting at a mic here okay okay get this
stuff into the schools thank you very
much are you a plant did I tell you to
say that no I'm a mom with kids in
school excellent even better okay public
schools that's right good excellent
question this this really is intended
for use in in that direction a couple of
steps first of all I did prepare a
teacher's guide to this questions from
all the way from the kind of simple
comprehension questions to very complex
critical thinking questions involving
the footnotes I mean I have a thousand
footnotes in here to referencing all the
original sources and pointing people in
those directions and even inviting
people to challenge my statements and so
on so we have that and that will be
available shortly and then we're also
going to work on you know there's a
question of how these things are going
to sort of get by the local school
boards which are Britain you know the
standard seem to be written more for a
traditional form of history so I'm going
to try to prepare in working with the
national standards a sort of master
little sheet which will be available you
know through with the just requested in
give me a couple months for the thing to
come out and with the teachers edition
with showing how this fits in with the
national standards so you can into
actually have some ammunition to try to
get it into your schools yeah how do we
work this just let me add something to
that I ran into this problem then when
people's history the United States came
out the problem was how to get it into
the schools when the principal Emma and
the school board and maybe the chair of
the Department of the school won't like
it and one thing that people did is they
simply photocopied
parts of the book and and so long as
we're free and easy mark febrile you are
mind the new press no but really very
often that's the only thing you can do I
mean where you can get it approved
officially great you know and what
happens is there's a progression where
people say this is what I found with the
book at first you know surreptitious
have photocopied chapters handed out to
students alongside the regular text and
then as you know the it the idea began
to seep into consciousness of the
educational world and become more
respectable than after a while yeah
adoptions and and approvals and so on so
I mean I don't know how legal this is
but but we don't care
let me say also about schools this is
written for a for just an oddity no high
school or college or general trade
audience but hopefully it would be
available for lower these stories in it
can be extracted this is apropos to
xeroxing so in other words a teacher
could take this and where the teachers
guide certainly develop all sorts of
lesson plans with this material yeah
yeah I was in binghamton new york
recently and in the newspaper i read a
controversy regarding an indian
holocaust memorial I wonder if you're
familiar with this apparently George
Washington ordered the Indians in that
region to run Binghamton he ordered
general Sheridan I guess to eradicate
the Indians men women and children
including their villages and I and I
looked up a little bit about this and
apparently this did happen Washington
gave the order and the Indians really
were many of them killed and the rest
were moved to or move themselves to
Niagara I wondered if I never heard this
before and I was amazed it appears to be
true are you familiar with this if it's
true why haven't we heard about this in
history before there was a major major
campaign against the Iroquois and by
general Sullivan and actually a lot of
his a lot of his officers kept journals
and the journals were fascinating
because they were like the body counts
you know for the Vietnam War oh yeah oh
yeah direct order and except they were
vegetable counts because this was the
idea was to starve them so they're the
orders were to burn every piece of
everything that was growing it was a
certain you know was that defoliation
early version of defoliation so they did
this they burned all the Indian fields
throughout throughout New York and of
course the following winter was a very
hard one in great starvation and it did
absolutely zero to stop the Indian raids
because what was the people who would
survive were the warriors they were
furious the next year of course was much
worse along the frontier but that's what
it was it was it was really a genocide
I'll type of operation in your and right
it's it's covered it's it's covered in
the book and then there
Frances where you can actually go back
to the original sources written by once
a once again reflected images because
the Indians actually there's some of
this there is a captured India Mary
Jamison was captured when she was a
child and became she married an Iroquois
warrior and she wrote something and she
wrote about the starvation that followed
and that's in here and then you can read
actually the accounts of the officers
themselves as well about this from
Washington in his what is it 1931
there's a 13 volume biography you're
probably familiar with that if it's the
other Fitzgerald it there some gives it
gives the order and you can look up
general than ever to Sullivan's journals
to and see his record yeah thank you
yeah yeah I just had a couple comments
mainly on doctors in speech I mean I
think he I'd like the part you talked
about how the u.s. is a history of class
oppression and racism and racial
exploitation a history just you know
like Harvard also has a history of class
exploitation and class oppression and
you also made the connection which about
what that you have to use the study of
history in terms of what to do to get
rid of this so I just wanted to address
what I think needs to be done about to
get rid of class exploitation to get rid
of class oppression and I'm a March
system a follower the smartest this
league we put out the paper workers
Vanguard and we think that in order to
get rid of racers and get rid of racial
oppression there has to be if you will
the history of a bottom a making of the
history through the bottom up in the
same way the Bolsheviks made history in
the bottom up which is to put the
working class in power through a third
American Revolution just like this of a
war smash slavery we think there needs
to be a revolution to smash class
slavery smash wage slavery and so I just
wanted to encourage everybody to check
out our paperwork with Vanguard and also
to read Marx which I think explains
history of capitalism how would you want
to comment I think I need to comment oh
then it's not really a question right
it's it's a manifesto which you know do
we need revolutions from below yeah
absolutely but you know that's a what
kind of revolutions how when well let
you know that's very complicated but
anyway it's a no a welcome point of view
there's a lot for your comments um one
of the things I think is that most of
our traditional history is tend to skew
heavily towards elite driven histories
as you both discuss today and the
revolutions certainly a great example of
that and some of those reasons for it
our contemporary and some of them are
interposed and not David Hackett Fisher
in Paul Revere's ride gives us a good
account of how the Lexington alarm which
had dozens and dozens and dozens of
artisans involved with became transposed
by Longfellow because of civil war
propaganda into a single rider a lone
voice in the night some of the reasons
why we have an elite history of the
revolution I think were contemporaneous
with the revolution itself and its
wondering if you might want to comment
on what were some of those reasons for
burnishing the elites or the perception
of the elites at the time and reasons
for the if you look at adams and
jefferson their self conscious of their
place in history and in most of the
quote founding fathers rights they're
speaking to posterity what do you see as
being some of the reasons for their own
skewing history in favor well they had a
very difficult job because they wanted
something that was called a revolution
but obviously they didn't want
revolution so you know they had a hard
it's hard balancing act and they wanted
to basically ally themselves with people
who did want a revolution and then
quickly distanced themselves from that
same from those same people and you know
it's a complex way in which we did in
which they did this and that's all I can
say they sort of managed to pull it off
which was and that's I guess it's to
their credit but but it was it was you
know after the revolution there was an
attempt
at another revolution let me just
speaking of shays rebellion which which
Howard mentioned remember I mentioned
the 1774 revolution which was the
revolution was to be the real overthrow
of the government throughout all of
Massachusetts that was in 1774 in 1786
exactly 12 years later to the day
actually one day less because it like in
Springfield it was August 30th and 12
years later was August twenty-ninth
because the way the courts were meeting
the exact same people showed up but not
quite as many of them and tried to do
the exact same thing they tried to
engage in a second revolution this is
something in the terms of the history of
shays rebellion it's just it's never
fully understood because people don't
understood the context that these guys
were just trying to do a repeat
performance and the iron you know the
result was the first one succeeded and
the second one failed and that's sort of
how you can mark what happened after the
revolution that was the mark that that
the Revolution was not going to the
second revolution the full social
revolution was not going to succeed that
there's a lot more to speak about that
I'm glad you raised the issue but you
know I mean that's a huge issue yeah and
that is that there's this continuity you
know that Ray is talking about you know
from 1774 1786 and of course before 1774
and after 17 86 but in the midst of the
revolution in the midst of the war
against England which presumably is you
know as Ray said you know the story is
of United colonists patriotic warrants
on button midst of that there are
mutinies which are class-based that is a
the soldier the privates are being
treated like dirt the officers are being
treated like kings and you know they're
getting a high pay and good clothes and
good food and having parties and so on
and and the and the Pirates uh not
giving any clothes not getting any pay
and being kept in when they want to be
mustered out that time to service us up
and so they mutiny
1781 their number in 1781 their the
mutiny of thousands of soldiers in the
Pennsylvania line and Washington has to
be very careful in dealing with that
because there's thousands of them and
he's worried and expresses this that
this is this may spread to the whole
Revolutionary Army and so he deals with
them by compromising but then shortly
after that there's another mutiny in the
New Jersey line we're only a few hundred
mutineers are involved at that point
Washington's get stuff and you know
there's a romanticized picture of
Washington which well as we see is
dispelled when you look at how he treats
black people and how he treats Indians
but also how he treats presumably his
own his own soldiers when they when he
feels he can handle the mutiny in new
jersey line his orders are shoot them
and so they take out by random actually
it's almost like the movie paths of
glory where they you know pick out at
random you know the troublemakers that
randomly pick them out and they have
them executed by the fellow mutineers I
think sometimes it's hard for people
whether historians are just students in
school to pursue lines of thought that
go against what the mainstream is
telling them is the right thing to
believe in what is oftentimes the more
easy thing to believe in and I've read a
couple of mr. Zins books and I feel like
I have a somewhat of an idea about how
that process occurred in his life but I
was just curious about when you made the
decision you mentioned earlier I don't
know jokingly or not about being in a
school of people's historians how do you
get to that place you know it's not like
your education probably led you to that
early on what makes you follow that path
i'm going to give you sort of an
academic version and a political and a
political activist version the academic
one is actually when i first ran into in
the in when i was in high school and I
ran into asta one of these collections
of slave narratives you know from the
WPA projects in the ba ba can lay my
burden down it was a collection of those
with the writers went down and collected
all the narratives I could not believe I
was reading these you know first
and accounts from slaves I was so struck
by this i mean i don't know hit me
deeply the other one is an acht activist
and really got me into the the power of
people's history was Howard Zinn and
Howard Zinn he doesn't know this I was
about to tell him the story this
afternoon and we ran out of time so I'm
tell until you know yeah right I know
because you've been we've been waiting
all this time right that's that's why
he's sitting there he's still waiting I
know right so here's what happened I'm
in the south and in 1964 working with
snake I was just a volunteer and and
meanwhile and this is a big year you
knows where the people are murdered and
everything and there's bombings and all
this is going on and then that we're
preparing for the mississippi freedom
democratic party to go to the convention
to challenge so anyway meanwhile what
what's in the press is usually still is
all this stuff about Martin Luther King
and the in the established leadership
and what I'm seeing on the ground is
this incredible I mean these people who
work with snick I couldn't believe them
I couldn't believe them I was just odd I
was like floored I mean this was like I
don't know to see their commitment and
the dangers they face every day in their
life force and their vitality and then
right then Howard Zinn comes out with a
book called sniff the new abolitionists
and it's amazing it gets the story
absolutely right and I had never I been
in the movement for a while at this time
and every time you're in the movie you
go to a demonstration then you read
about it in the paper the next day you
know what that wasn't the demonstration
I was at and here there's a political
event and I'm seeing and he's writing
about it from the bottom up and this was
before that that term bottom-up had even
been coined and he's doing it and that
really impacted me that that could be
done that you know so indirectly most
people here are kind of affected by the
People's History you know you know I
guess we shared enough in common that we
go that far back
so Howard is no johnny-come-lately to
this movement yeah I was fascinated by
which were saying about the Indians and
enslaved on blacks running to the
British Army could you speculate whether
they would have been better off if the
British you know had in fact prevailed
if the British had prevailed what once
they ran to the army they didn't really
at the there's two stages the early part
of the war where they were actually
technically offered their freedom and a
few perceived it but not that many and
then later in the war where they went by
the droves that's where the tens of
thousands went and and at this time it
was just sort of an implicit thing maybe
you'll get free and they weren't
basically what happened they would
become servants of officers they would
be placed in very hard labor situations
some of them would actually be taken off
as slaves by by loyalists so very few
really out of out of approximately
eighty thousand slaves that ran to the
British for their freedom three thousand
exactly received their freedom and I'd
say that is the number of slaves that
were recorded as as being taken to
Canada you know for the you know as free
slaves after the war now it's hard to
say what would have happened what did
happen is the revolution for the
institution of slavery attended to
rigidify that institution because before
the Revolution the institution of
slavery hadn't really been challenged
and this did challenge it and that
caused the slave owners to create a kind
of reaction and so a lot of the tale of
the revolution for its slaves is
increasing reaction at home momentary
kind of freedom some of these people
actually there were maroon communities
where they actually were free for a
while so there was kind of a momentary
taste of freedom and then after war
clamped down totally that's where you
get the rigidify laid codes they came
right in the wake of the revolution
I really am enjoying this session at
particularly what the questions that
came out because that made concrete some
of the implications for doing a new
social disagree with the looking at it
more in a more comprehensive holistic
way one of the things that I wonder if
I'm gonna get your book to see it to
what extent can we spell out make
obvious how our understanding of where
we are today is changed and different
because of what we now know about what
happened then there isn't we know that
it was complicated there are many
different groups with different
particular perspectives and issues it
wasn't organized and integrated as as it
seems in retrospect the future always
looks uncertain the past looks like it's
inevitable so the question is when we do
these kinds of histories is it clear
that we try to spell out how our
understanding is now different and more
adequate to the outcome that we saw in
the more limited histories from top down
in your book you try to show how our
understanding about the American
Revolution is either deepens or in some
way the morning but so are there lessons
we look at that as this period unless we
control for today okay just as being
stated yeah well remember I said at the
beginning that when we learn history is
how we learn the grammar of the
political process you know how we learn
to interpret the political process so
when and I use that in a negative way
because we learn the elite history
that's what we're learning so you can
just take the converse of that answer
your question if you learn the history
if you growing up you learn that people
are proactive that people gather
together that in a real in what
democracy means is not voting there's a
lot more than voting it's people
gathering together for their own
interests and standing up for their
interests and so on you take that kind
of image of that's you know that grammar
and translated to the present
presumably you will make that a much
more normal or accepted or integral part
of contemporary society these things
aren't and it's no accident really that
this kind of history is coming out today
I mean this history really is in it
sends it coming it's flowing directly
from the 1960s the historians that are
really I mean a lot of this is based on
historical research which has come
directly out of the 1960s by a great
wave of new social history real I had an
opportunity to learn about American
economic and social history and I used
level as an example I learned from my
colleagues be taught a course in an
incidence break fashion I understood
much more deeply how the feminist
movement of the course of our very
developed the unintended consequence of
the Industrial Revolution getting sheep
farm girls to come in was in the course
of the learning discipline work an
organization being educated by people
like Thoreau in order to please have
funds they had a special educational
program and then when there was a
cutback in work because the merchant
Prince's who couldn't sell apply the
tray to China had an opportunity to
invest in developing textile industries
overbuilt they cut their wages of these
women the women then organized as many
of us know and it shows how the nature
of life itself as walking predicted by
can walk the actual experience of
organization transforms people and
develop leadership for the next several
generation women who were active in the
feminist movement and in the
abolitionist movement and the line so I
think there's a lot of important
the observations we get enlightened
lessons and thank you for tonight right
and the message is that if we do this
with any particular period or subject in
history if you take that attitude you're
going to wind up with that kind of
impact on contemporary consciousness
thank you right right yeah we're told we
have three more questions these three
people so we we are told that anonymous
right yeah I just like to commend you
both because not only does your work
bring more perspective but it brings
passion to education so thank you thank
you